what's
did you say bitcoin poker yeah what's
bitcoin poker so you have to understand
i was 14 years old right yes
so how is a 14 year old with wonderful
parents who care about him yeah
and probably don't want him playing
poker yeah
um going to start playing poker because
i wanted i wanted to challenge i loved
the challenge i loved the competition
and i realized the answer was probably
bitcoin
because the implications of that and uh
they had
they had these uh free world tournaments
which for those of you don't know what
free rules are there's these
promotional tournaments that sites put
on where they'll put like a few dollars
in
and then thousands of people sign up and
the winners get like a dollar
and i started there and i worked my way
up and that's amazing
what's your sense about from that time
to today
of the growth of the cryptocurrency
community i'm actually having
like four or five conversation with
bitcoin
proponents bitcoin maximus and like all
these
i'm just having all these cryptocurrency
conversations currently
because there's so many brilliant like
technically brilliant but also
financially and philosophically
brilliant people in those communities
it's fascinating with the explosion of
impact
like and also if you look into the
future the possible revolutionary impact
on society in general but what's your
sense about this whole growth of bitcoin
i'm definitely less knowledgeable on the
currency
again like programming it was a means to
an end yes
right um what i will say is that there
was this amazing community that grew out
of it
and you'd have people who were willing
to
stake me or have me be their horse and
they're my backer
for having never met me for
literally full bitcoin tournaments like
full bitcoin entry
tournaments and i get a percentage of
the profits and they get a percentage
and to have that level of community for
that degree of money
i mean it gives you hope about the
potential for
you know humans to act in mutual
best interest with a degree of trust
yeah there's a really fascinating strong
community there but
speaking of like bringing out the best
of human nature
it's a community that's currently
struggling a little bit
uh in terms of their ability to
communicate in a positive inspiring way
like the bitcoin folks and we talk about
this a lot they
um i i honestly think they have a lot
a lot of love in their hearts and minds
but they just kind of naturally
because the world has been like
institutions and uh the centralized
powers have been
sort of mocking and uh fighting them for
many years
that they've become sort of worn down
and cynical
and so they tend to be a little bit more
aggressive and negative on the
internet in the way they communicate
especially on twitter
and it's just created this whole
community of
basically being derisive and mocking and
trolling and all this kind of stuff
yeah but people are trying to you know
as the as the bitcoin community grows as
the cryptocurrency community grows
they're trying to revolutionize that
aspect too so they're trying to find the
positive core and grow
uh and and grow in that way so it's it's
a it's fascinating because i think all
of us
are trying to find the positive aspects
of ourselves and trying to learn
how to communicate in a positive way
online it's like the internet has been
around social networks haven't been
around that long we're trying to
we're trying to figure this thing out
you